theatrics of johnny depp and amber heard
took another dramatic turn today as
depth's former lover kate moss the
supermodel gave evidence from her home
in gloucestershire she made a very brief
appearance specifically to testify that
she was never pushed down the stairs by
debt contrary to rumors resurfaced by
amber heard in the case two weeks ago
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him did mr depp push you in any
way down the stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any
stairs i'm joined number sibling friend
of kate most janice dickenson janet
great to have you on the show and you
know kate and johnny well um
i thought it was a very big moment in
this trial because amber heard it tried
to use this
story which everyone thought was true
about johnny depp hurling kate moss down
the stairs as evidence this is what he
does and why she feared for her own
safety and there was kate moss who never
ever speaks in public so it's sort of
fascinating popping up purely for a few
minutes just to say actually that story
is completely untrue and he never did
anything like that to me in our
relationship what did you make of it
i think
just from personal experience knowing
when kate moss was indeed the girlfriend
of johnny depp he was the boyfriend i
was on a flight from
virgin islands to st bart's and the both
of them had clearly been drinking as i
was clearly drinking on this air flight
and he was a total gentleman to her
and he was a total gentleman to me and
i've
ran into johnny depp several times in
los angeles
uh you know after after happy hour has
like long set
the sun has set on happy hour he's he
was never violent towards anyone and as
far as amber heard saying that um she
had been
tossed down flights of stairs or or
beaten up by johnny depp or anything
like that i don't believe it in for one
new york city second i mean look look
what happened between the two of them
she severed his fingertip off
right i'm sorry
i mean i i'm going to say janice i've
watched the whole the whole thing from
time to time uh the clips and so on
we're just increasing kind of revulsion
really it's like the worst dirty linen
ever washed isn't it
don't you feel dirty watching this trial
i mean i have been watching it like this
but i'm planted to it at night and this
is this is a big thing here in los
angeles this trial and
i'm opposed to amber heard
for my very own personal reasons about
women's rights as you know i was raped
by bill cosby uh during the cosby trials
and i went up against this monster and
testified for andrea constance on her
behalf well here i would i would be
ready to testify for johnny depp that
amber heard
had a f had a fledgling career when she
first met when she first did the rum
diaries with johnny depp and johnny depp
is this mega superstar i think the other
thing is i think i think the bottom line
with this is i think that um kate moss
today in a very powerful few minutes may
have completely swung this back johnny
depp's way because she nailed a lie that
amber heard was trying to use i gotta
leave it there janice i'm sorry we run
out of time but thank you very much well
thank you i'm a big fan piers big fan of
yours thank you thank you very much
appreciate it